[Music]
the king attracts crowds and more
recently protests too
they wouldn't have shouted at the queen
but Republicans believe a new monarch is
their moment support and donations they
say have increased and so too the action
they're taking with a protest planned
along the coronation route
I think the coronation day will be a
moment the biggest moment we've ever had
when you know if they are right that
millions of people are going to be
watching the coronation the millions of
people are going to be seeing us and
then sitting up and going well hang on a
minute why are people objecting to this
and and finding out so I think it's
going to be
a significant game changer for the for
the movement a recent poll found nearly
two-thirds of people either don't care
or care very little about the king's
coronation and they're significantly
less appetite for Street parties
compared with last year's Jubilee
long-term studies of attitudes to the
monarchy show support is slipping in
1983 we were seeing about nine in ten of
us saying that it was really important
that the royal family continued going
forward which is a sort of message about
their popularity and their relevance
today that sort of figure is around
about just over half around 55 and of
course if you get close to that 50
approval rating if you like then more
and more questions will be asked around
you know the funding and everything else
associated with the monarchy potentially
if the downward Trend can
a lot though depends on younger
Generations where approval ratings are
currently lowest
but even if public supports falling any
change would need political support too
the wedding Essence have to be a
government that is interested in this
and you know there have long been lots
of proposals to replace the raw
prerogative or to put it on a more
modern democratic basis
but once the political party gets into
office
they start to get focused on other more
immediate matters such as the economy or
the cost of living
Royal popularity always Peaks after big
events like the coronation but the real
test will be what happens once that's
all over Laura bundock Sky News